a buffer solution consists of a
significant amount of a weak acid and
its conjugate base
let's say we have a generic weak acid h
a
and its conjugate base a minus and we're
going to use some particulate diagrams
to try to understand how buffers work so
for our first particulate diagram let's
count out how many particles we have of
each so first let's count how many has
we have so there's one two three four
five has
and there's also for a minus there's one
two three four five a minuses
and when looking at a particulate
diagram of a buffer usually water
molecules are omitted for clarity and
also keep in mind that this particulate
diagram is just meant to represent a
small portion of the solution so we can
get an idea about what's happening in
the entire solution
also notice that like water molecules
cations are also left out of the
particulate diagram so we have five h a
particles and five a minus particles in
our aqueous solution having equal
amounts of a weak acid and its conjugate
base is a good buffer solution
let's see what happens to the buffer
solution if we add in a small amount of
acid so here i'm drawing in an h plus
ion and let's think about adding this h
plus ion to our buffer solution
when the h plus ion is added to the
solution the base that is present will
react with the h plus ion to neutralize
it so the added h plus reacts with a
minus to form h a so for the particulate
diagrams this added h plus is going to
react with one of the a minuses present
in the buffer solution so the h plus and
the a minus form an h a so we're going
to go from five h a's to six h a so
let's look at this next particular
diagram here we can see there are now
six has in the solution so let me write
down six here
and since we started with five a minuses
and we lost one we should have only four
a minuses in solution now so let's write
down a four here so you started off with
five has and five a minuses and upon the
addition of a small amount of acid the
acid was neutralized by the base that
was present and we formed six has and
four a minuses so a buffer solution
resists changes in ph so the added h
plus was neutralized by the presence of
the base if the buffer solution had not
been present if we just had some water
and we added some h plus the ph would
have changed dramatically one way to
write the acid base neutralization
reaction that occurred is to write h
plus plus a minus goes to h a
however since h3o plus and h plus are
used interchangeably in chemistry we
could have also written the net ionic
equation as h3o plus plus a minus goes
to h a and h2o
next let's go back to our middle
particulate diagram with 5 h a and 5 a
minus and this time let's try to add
some hydroxide ions to the solution so
think about
let me go ahead and draw an arrow here
so we're going to add a small amount of
base to our buffer
solution the hydroxide anion will react
with the weak acid that is present h a
to form h2o and a minus so for the
particulate diagrams we can think about
this o h minus reacting with one of the
has to form h2o and an a minus since
we're using up one of the has we're
gonna go from five has down to
four has so let me write down here four
h a's and when this h a reacts it's
gonna turn into an a minus so we're
gonna go from five a minuses
up to six so let's count them over here
one two three four five
six so let's write in six a minuses
if there was no buffer present and we're
just adding hydroxide anions to water
the ph would change dramatically however
with a buffer present since there is a
weak acid ha present to neutralize the
added hydroxide anions the buffer
solution resists a change to the ph
so let's summarize how buffer solutions
work
if we add a small amount of an acid h
plus to a buffer solution the conjugate
base that's present a minus neutralizes
the added acid therefore the buffer
solution resists a change in ph
and if we add a small amount of a base
the weak acid that's present will
neutralize the hydroxide anions
therefore the buffer solution resists a
change in ph
let's say we have an aqueous solution of
acetic acid and an aqueous solution of
sodium acetate
and let's say we have equal moles of
acetic acid and of sodium acetate mixing
these two solutions together would form
a buffer solution to understand why this
forms a buffer solution let's first
think about acetic acid acetic acid is a
weak acid and only part partially
ionizes an aqueous solution therefore in
aqueous solution we have mostly acetic
acid ch3cooh
sodium acetate is a soluble salt and it
dissociates completely in aqueous
solution therefore in aqueous solution
we have sodium cations and acetate
anions
ch3coo minus
the acetate anion is the conjugate base
to acetic acid therefore in aqueous
solution we have a weak acid and its
conjugate base and so we have a buffer
solution
if we try adding a small amount of acid
to the buffer solution the conjugate
base that's present will react with the
acid and neutralize it so in the balance
net ionic equation the added acid
hydronium ion h3o plus reacts with the
acetate anion to form acetic acid and
water so the added hydronium ion was
neutralized and the buffer has resisted
a dramatic change in ph
if we try adding a small amount of base
to the buffer solution the weak acid
that is present will neutralize the
added base so in the balanced net ionic
equation hydroxide anions react with
acetic acid to form the acetate anion
and water
so the added base was neutralized so to
summarize the acetic acid acetate buffer
system resists dramatic changes in ph
when small amounts of acid or base are
added and i just noticed i forgot to
include the l for liquid for water in
the balanced and net ionic equations